quando mi hanno chiesto di partecipare a
questo Ted ho pensato alle prime tre
cose che mi fanno più paura nella vita e
al primo posto ci sono le malattie mie
ma soprattutto delle persone a cui
voglio bene Poi c'è la paura dello
sradicamento la paura di sentirmi
straniera e la paura del palcoscenico
ora la palcoscenico Naturalmente come
tutti gli altri la sto affrontando in
questo momento quindi non parlerò di
questo
delle malattie neanche voglio parlare e
mi concentrerò su questa paura di mezzo
è la paura di essere straniera che mi
sono accorta proprio ragionando su
questo Ted che
alla fine è entrata nel mio lavoro
e si è legata a doppio filo anche con
con quello che scrivo
Non che io scriva dei libri autobiogra
buonissima inevita inevitabilmente si
finisce sempre per mettere del nostro
nelle cose che facciamo e ogni cosa che
scriviamo se vogliamo può essere letta
un po' come un diario visto che porta
tracce inevitabilmente delle nostre
esperienze delle nostre vite dei nostri
pensieri e quindi la paura di sentirmi
straniera inevitabilmente entrata nei
miei libri Quindi parto proprio da un
dato veramente di aristico ho fatto una
ventina di traslochi nella mia vita di
cui due intercontinentali ho vissuto in
molti posti diversi tra cui un'isola
piccolissima un paese di poche migliaia
di abitanti le capitali di tre diversi
paesi Parigi Roma e Washington e non è
stato detto ma in realtà io sono
originaria di Lugo perché sono nata qua
a Lugo di Romagna mi sento in qualche
modo di appartenere anche alla Romagna
anche se di fatto non ci ho mai vissuto
Ci sono soltanto nata e sono stata
sradicata talmente tante volte che
spesso non è semplice per me rispondere
a una domanda facilissima quella proprio
che ci identifica per prima di dove sei
A seconda del contesto di chi me lo
chiede di
dove mi trovo modulo la risposta sono
appunto nata a Lugo ma il mio accento
ovviamente tradisce una matrice Toscana
ho vissuto a Roma per il periodo più
lungo della mia vita ma mi sento
comunque gigliese perché anche se ha
vissuto lì soltanto i primi otto anni
della mia vita Ho un passaporto che dice
che sono italiana è un altro passaporto
che dice che sono americana per cui
posso dire a buon titolo di essermi più
volte nella vita sentita sradicata
ora nella maggior parte dei casi in cui
appunto mi sono trasferita
perlomeno tutte le volte che l'ho fatto
nell'età adulta è stato questo il frutto
di una scelta l'ho fatto volontariamente
non sono state delle scelte forzate da
necessità o da mancanza di alternative
possibile per cui anche rispetto ad
altre storie che abbiamo sentito molto
drammatiche di persone che si sono
dovute sentire straniere per forza io
l'ho fatto sempre in una condizione di
privilegio ma anche il privilegio di
poter scegliere non è al riparo da
conseguenze soprattutto non è al riparo
dalla paura nel mio caso la paura di
sentirmi straniera è sostenuta da una
sorta di treppiede di altre paure
che sono la paura di non essere
riconosciuta la paura di non essere
capita
e la paura della solitudine la paura di
non essere riconosciuta una paura che mi
porto dietro Fin dall'infanzia che è
segnato la mia vita in varie occasioni
anche in maniera molto
divertenti proprio con dei fatti
risilaranti a partire da quando appunto
al saggio di danza da piccola Mio padre
ha fotografato per tutto il tempo
un'altra bambina
molti altri episodi sono leggendari
anche tra i miei amici una sera che ho
passato con un editor a una festa per un
premio letterario rincontrato questo
stesso editor con il quale avevo
chiacchierato tutta la sera a cena a una
riunione due giorni dopo e mi si è
ripresentato come se non mi avesse mai
visto e questa cosa in effetti mi ha un
po' segnata questa idea di proprio di
essere un po' invisibile o di non
lasciare veramente una traccia di me
tant'è che non escludo che un po' abbia
anche influito sul fatto che io abbia
voluto scrivere nella vita ho detto
Magari se non mi possono vedere magari
mi possono leggere e essere apolide però
essere sradicati essere in un altro
paese diventa la massima espressione in
certi casi di questa invisibilità perché
all'improvviso
sei proprio invisibile sia per le
istituzioni che per la società ma
soprattutto per altre persone che in un
nuovo contesto non ti conoscono quindi
ti vedono ma non ti guardano e si è
insignificanti sostanzialmente si
finisce per essere proprio dei
significanti privi di significato E
questa sensazione
È una sensazione orribile perché
essere trasparenti e come non esistere
molti casi
E questa paura si affianca a quella che
io definito la seconda gamba del
treppiede di queste paure che è la paura
di non essere capiti Ovviamente
per me che scrivo credo che sia forse
una delle massime espressioni della
del terrore cioè il fatto di voler
comunicare e dire qualcosa ma non essere
non essere capito oppure essere
completamente fraintesi Penso che sia il
peggior incubo per uno scrittore ma in
generale Ecco trasferirsi in un paese in
cui non si parla la lingua significa
limitarsi significa avere delle
difficoltà ovviamente anche nell'essere
accettati E inevitabilmente non avendo a
disposizione un lessico preciso anche
per dire le cose che vuoi o per
esprimere dei pensieri profondi finisci
per dare una una versione limitata di te
stesso io insomma con le lingue che non
pazzesco bene Mi sento inevitabilmente
più stupida perché sento
appunto di essere un po' dentro questo
Bosco dentro cui ti perdi mentre la casa
è dove ti capiscono la casa corrisponde
alla lingua madre ora quando nessuno ti
riconosce e quando nessuno ti capisce
è lì che si forma anche il terzo piede
di questo treppiede che sorregge la
paura
dello sradicamento e che è la paura
della solitudine nel momento in cui
appunto
ti senti straniero ti senti invisibile
per gli altri non ti senti capito anche
se sei il più privilegiato degli
espatriati comunque
temi di essere in questa condizione di
solitudine terribile in cui se hai
bisogno di aiuto nessuno te lo può dare
Io ho scoperto che in tutti i miei
romanzi che sono comunque romanzi di
finzione sono ambientati in luoghi e
anche in tempi molto diversi
e
ho infilato queste queste paure
per esempio la protagonista del mio
primo romanzo isole minori si sente
straniera quando viene portata via dalla
sua Isola e soprattutto si sente
straniera anche quando torna perché
sente che gli Isolani non la accolgono
più come una di loro e quindi la
considerano che loro una straniera
c'è una frase in cui questa protagonista
dice io non ero più gigliese Forse non
lo ero mai stata perché anche quando ci
vivevo ero comunque figlia di Forestieri
e si sente anche invisibile col passare
degli anni e quella senza prolungata ho
fatto sempre più fatica a essere
riconosciuta credo che il mio tratto più
caratteristico sia la mancanza di un
contorno nitido è qualcosa che forse mi
accomuna con l'isolagnità con lo
scivolar via dell'Acqua o il mutare del
paesaggio al vento
anche nel mio secondo romanzo Il
giardino dei mostri che è un romanzo
ambientato in un luogo di villeggiatura
che diventa all'improvviso
gentrificato da persone dell'altra
società che cominciano a frequentarlo
in un certo senso la paura del dello
straniamento del non sentirsi più a casa
diventa il motore delle vicende
nel romanzo poi tra l'altro una delle
protagoniste che è una quindicenne che
si chiama Annamaria si ritrova a
straniera a se stessa perché non si
riconosce nel suo stesso nome in un
mondo di Lavini e Ginevra Lei si chiama
Annamaria e sente che questo nome che
addirittura viene abbreviato quasi
troncato dialetto con Annamaria lei
viene collocata dal suo nome in uno
status di subalternità diciamo rispetto
alle ragazze di città Infatti ho
mostrato questa frase
non riconoscersi nel proprio nome era
stato il primo passo nell'insicurezza
lei era Annamaria Annamaria la figlia di
Sauro il buttero e nel momento in cui
qualcuno si rivolgeva a lei ancora prima
di aver pronunciato il comando che in
genere seguiva c'era già tutto lo
svantaggio socio economico Nel mio
ultimo romanzo che è uscito quest'estate
sentito la erosione ci sono tre fratelli
che sono alle prese con la svendita
della loro casa sul mare questo proprio
un romanzo ambientato negli Stati Uniti
Quindi lontano anche dagli altri due e
di questi tre protagonisti visto che
appunto si stanno separando da questa
casa che ormai è impossibile da
mantenere perché è stata costruita su un
tratto di costa che è stato fortemente
colpito dagli eventi atmosferici e
dall'erosione creata dal cambiamento
climatico c'è uno dei dei fratelli che
ho scoperto poi dopo soffrire di una
di un sentimento nuovo che si chiama la
solastalgia è una parola che è stata
coniata di recente da un da un filosofo
australiano che si chiama glennalbrecht
e appunto è una parola che assomiglia
alla nostalgia ma è composta da
dalla parola latina Solarium Che
significa sollievo e dal gira dolore
quindi sostanzialmente il dolore del
sollievo la definizione
dell'enciclopedia Treccani lo definisce
come uno stato di angoscia che affligge
Chi ha subito una tragedia ambientale
provocata dall'intervento maldestro
dell'uomo sulla natura Ecco in questo
caso
il nostro protagonista
è addolorato di non avere più il
sollievo della sua casa e a un certo
punto dice non pensavo che mi sarebbe
mancata la mia casa sul mare pur stando
dentro la casa sul mare quindi lui si
sente e straneo e solo in un luogo che
gli era familiare che era la sua casa
ora
si dice sempre che partire è un po'
morire questo lo sappiamo tutti molto
meno si dice A proposito del fatto che
partire sentirsi sradicati significa
anche provare paura però una paura che
non uccide una paura che poi con il
tempo si può affievolire
spesso magari mettendo nuove Radici in
un luogo posto oppure
semplicemente accettandola una paura che
resta lì che resta anche quando si torna
perché luoghi diversi ci hanno cambiato
hanno cambiato la nostra identità Non ci
riconosciamo più a casa in nessuno dei
posti in cui siamo stati prima ma casa è
ognuno dei posti in cui ci siamo sentiti
a casa almeno temporaneamente e a quel
punto la casa è questo eterno sentirsi
altrove
Quindi è una paura che si inizia a
riconoscere e che non spaventa più e
anzi può diventare come è stato nel mio
caso il motore di molte storie perché di
fatto cambiare muoversi viaggiare
cercare di adattarsi cercare di farsi
capire o di farsi accettare in una
situazione nuova sono proprio i semi
stessi della narrazione c'è una
bellissima frase in Libra di Don De
Lillo che dice le cose migliori
risplendono di paura e questo è forse il
modo in cui ho affrontato la mia
personale paura cercando di trasformarla
in materiale narrativo l'ho come un po'
sublimata in un atto creativo
e spero di mescolandola insieme
all'immaginazione di averla trasformata
in qualcos'altro qualcosa di splendente